a new front has opened in the conflict
between the eu and belarus as brussels
accuses minsk of using migrants as
political pawns
european council president charles
michel has visited the border between
belarus and their eu member lithuania
where record numbers of migrants have
arrived over recent weeks
michelle says belarus is allowing
migrants to cross
deliberately in order to put pressure on
the eu
it comes after the eu had recently
imposed a new sanctions against belarus
and lithuania has declared a state of
emergency
dw correspondent constantine eggert is
covering that story from the lithuanian
capital belarus
welcome constantine how serious is this
problem
it is serious uh last in the last 24
hours
there were 130 plus migrants that
crossed the border which is i think more
than the whole of last year and
this has been repeating now for days
over a week at least or probably even
more
uh so the situation is becoming very
serious and uh
charles michelle promised today uh
his help to or the eu's help brother to
um the lithuanian president guitarist
and the lithuanian government which is
struggling to uh
basically accommodate all those people
uh tent
uh incumbents are being built
as we speak right now and the lithuanian
migration service
said that all the asylum applications uh
will be really really very very much
backlogged
uh if they're all filed uh at once so
that means that these people
will have to wait uh for the decision of
their fate
for quite a long time and stay in
lithuania for quite a long time
and the accusation is that belarusian's
leader alexander lukashenko is sending
migrants towards the eu uh is that borne
out by by what you've seen
yes definitely so and uh data from
uh the lithuanian border does show that
basically
the lithuanian bell russian frontiers
become
completely porous people are just
climbing over a fence and
running across the border belarus
suspended
his participation in eu's partnership
what's even more important
uh in the eu re migrant readmission
agreement
which actually obliged belarus to take
illegal migrants crossing from his side
back and um last week lukashenko
announced that uh
he opens a visa-free regime with 73
countries mostly asia africa
for five days i mean national nationals
from these countries could come
for five days in belarus it's basically
like an open house invitation
uh to come and cross into the eu from
belarus
and he's punishing the eu is he
yes he does for the eu imposing
sanctions
on uh his regime for intercepting a
ryanair plane in the end of may and
arresting uh a russian opposition figure
who was on board
and this uh many uh eu leaders claimed
was
the de facto act of air piracy
uh what's more important uh the uh
many people here in vilnius in in the
political circles
are saying that lukashenko wouldn't have
been able to do that
without a very very clear nod
from vladimir putin in the kremlin
because
he is very much lucashank is very much
dependent on
moscow's support in his survival so
quite a few people here not officially
but quite i think
loudly saying it unofficially that uh
this
is not only lukashenko's war by proxy on
the eu
it is also the kremlin all right dw
correspondent constantine eggert in
vilnius
lithuania thank you
you